there's also sorrow and new anger in
chicago this morning over the deadly
police shooting of a 13-year-old boy
officials revealed body cam video of the
shooting yesterday prompting a nighttime
protest adam toledo was shot and killed
last month by an officer responding to
an apparent
shooting police say adam was holding a
gun at the time
the family's lawyer denies that however
the officer eric stillman
is on administrative leave during the
investigation and his lawyer calls the
shooting tragic
but said stillman was left with no other
option
adriana diaz is in chicago for us
adriana good morning to you
good morning tony there's still so many
questions that need to be answered but
just like in minnesota where protesters
are demanding police accountability in
the death of duante wright
and that's happening near where derek
chovin is being tried for the killing of
george floyd
here in chicago demonstrators are adding
another name to their calls
for an end of police violence and that
is 13 year old adam toledo
the images you're about to see are
really hard to watch we want to warn you
they are disturbing now you want to say
oh let's calm the city down
but when do you say let's calm these
killings down at the police department
overnight protests in chicago were tense
with demonstrators staring down police
still reeling from the body camera video
released just hours earlier late last
month officer eric stillman responded to
reports of gunshots
a chase ensued as soon as he got on the
scene and
19 seconds after exiting his car
he fired a single shot that struck
13-year-old adam toledo in the chest
the boy died at the scene
a wider angle of the incident appears to
show toledo put his hand on one side of
the wooden fence before turning
the police released this blown-up image
they say shows toledo with a gun
in body camera footage a gun is seen on
the ground
but in a freeze frame when toledo was
shot both hands appeared to be empty
toledo's mother spoke days after the
shooting they had a lot of options
but not kill them they couldn't shoot us
and
hit his leg his arm up in the air
i don't know but i killed my baby last
night toledo's family attorney adina
weiss-ortiz
told us the boy was obeying orders when
he was killed
everybody needs to recognize that child
was given a directive
he complied he surrendered he turned to
the officer with his hands up
and then he was shot what do you make of
the
freeze frame that the police has
released where they say
this is a gun in adam's right hand i see
a blurry image of thought something
but i can't tell you what is in his hand
they can't tell you what's in his hand
at this point we don't know what if
anything
was in that child's hand and if i can't
see it in the real time video
which the officer was looking at him in
real time
how could everybody say that he had a
gun in his hand that officer had
eight tenths of a second to determine if
that weapon was still
in his hand or not period but john
cadenzara
the president of the chicago police
union said the officer
was justified we do not have to wait to
be shot to respond
the officer had every reason to believe
that that offender was turning and
pointing the gun at him
that night toledo was with 21 year old
ruben roman who has been arrested
now police say the gunshots they were
originally responding to were fired by
roman toledo's family attorney says
adam was a good kid he was a little
timid his family said he loved to play
with legos
and he dreamed of one day becoming a
police officer
gail adriana thank you you're right
this is a very tough case this happened
at 2 40 in the morning
adam toledo is 13 years old out with a
21 year old
and it does appear cops are responding
to shots fired let's start with that so
they're going already sort of on
heightened alert he's running running
running that's true
and the the lawyer's right i can't tell
if that's a gun either but when you look
at the video
that's clearly a gun that's on the
street on the behind the fence
it's also clear that he dropped
something and when you listen to what
the police union said
he had less than a second the police
officer yeah to judge i mean so
i think there are many cases here i
think it's a good time to remember that
police are human beings too
yes and there lately you know there's
been a lot of
vitriol against the police i understand
that too but i also
have to say they're human too and he had
less than a second to make a
determination he was also in an exposed
position open an alley
yes yeah as adriana said there are a lot
of
questions in that case